once the season's over I just hope
you'll hit unblock because I do miss
seeing the dancing
I'll unblock you okay I'll take it I'll
unblock you it was for my mental health
I had to do it I had to do it I do not
take it personally good
um I hear you made quite the entrance on
stage
and I flipped them off I got booed
that's what I did I got booed and then I
flipped them off oh you can't show that
I know but I'll tell you what it was so
fun I loved it so much everyone was so
worried for me and I was like why are
you worried it's fabulous I'm like a
wrestler I'm like WME
I think I made it you are the biggest
bully in Hollywood and everyone knows it
how long until we put biggest bully in
Hollywood on some merch
well I'm sure it's already on merch
right I think it already is there
um I think it was kind of clever my
putting it under my m m I thought that
was you didn't see it because you're
blocked no
I saw it you know people screenshot and
post sales I know so anyway I'll unblock
you and I thought that was quite clever
of me actually to do that with the
Eminem because you know I love to flip
the switch was this inspired by the
Yemen at all no not at all but I think
that we could say it it is but no this
is my friend Alex Perry who sent me this
suit and it's just like how could you
not wear it right fabulous we got two
more parts of this reunion to watch
yeah what can you tease me with we see
you say put me on pause put me on pause
we see you going head-to-head with the
Miss Hilton give me a tease for what's
to come and where you left things off
with this group well there's going to be
a couple of surprises that you're not
gonna expect
let me tell you that and more of the
story is going to be told and some
denials of the story are going to happen
all of a sudden the story is being
denied when somebody apologized but now
she's denying it happens so I think
that'll be interesting because she's
going to come in like that she's going
to deny the whole thing do you think the
truth will be out there by the end of
all three episodes well I think the
truth always comes out I don't know if
it will be out there because people
believe what they want you can't you
can't control what people are going to
believe
I can tell you that I tell the truth and
I've always told the truth so whatever
you believe you believe
and how do we end it with this group
um you know we just had a really good
panel other than the bill other than the
boo I mean us as a group we have a
really good time and we really care
about each other I will tell you that
it's a hard show to do as you know
um but at the end of the day I really
care about these women
and you're one of the All-Stars of all
time whether they push pause on you or
not or whether they boo me or not
no one's ever going to push pause on me
I can tell you that that'll never happen
you see me or you won't there ain't no
pause happening
[Music]